So the first genes that we look at from a dietary standpoint are these HLA genes.
So this is kind of, that's a little snippet, that little clip is a clip from my software.
So a patient would receive a whole giant printout of about 30 some pages that we would look
at.
And it's very daunting, really, from a patient perspective.
So I try to explain it and understand, I require all my patients, if we're going to go through
a genetic profile, to watch my videos under the genetic tab, which is a little daunting
to itself.
But if you watch it a few times, I'm not trying to say that you have to be like knowledgeable
in all this, but it's almost like we're speaking a little different language.
So the more you can know, I think the better you can understand why I'm making recommendations.
So these first HLA genes are genes that affect gluten sensitivity.
So when you look at this profile, like you're going to see a whole bunch of these steps,
if you stay with me for these few hours, it has the gene there, the HLA DQA1, and then the
gene name after it, you see the top one on there, and then there's a blank because this
particular individual who I cut and pasted this off of does not have a defect there.
So you want to have a blank here, my pointer work, oh, it doesn't work on the screen, great.
So you want to have a blank after where it says in the column of variant.
I use the term defect, that's because I'm used to using that, a better term would be variant
because some of these variants can be actually beneficial to have, most of them art.
So that person does not have a variant in that particular gene.
These are the known genes that affect gluten sensitivity.
Now I think somebody's going to be talking about gluten sensitivity in a little bit, so
I'll leave this alone, but when I see a genetic profile like this, and the person has a double
allele defect to that bottom one, do you see that?
So they have a two there, so they inherited a gene from their mother and from their father,
and a single allele defect to that middle one, do you see that?
So as you're going to see some other categories of genes that we're going to talk about,
when this particular individual has a smothering of defects throughout all the genes,
I would say this isn't all that bad, but when a person has any defects in this, I would say
you shouldn't be eating gluten from a genetic standpoint.
So everything we're going to be talking about today, and if we do a gene profile on you,
we're only talking about your genes.
So there are other reasons why a person should change their diet.
So a person can have no defects in their HLA genes for gluten, and yet still have gluten sensitivity.
Because gluten sensitivity has to do with an immune reaction to the peptides of the protein
glianin that it really has much less to do with a genetic predisposition.
Follow me? But that's a lecture in itself, and I'll save that for another person.
So the MCM6 gene has to do with lactose intolerance. Now, I don't usually take people off of
dairy because of lactose anyhow. We take people off of dairy because of the protein and dairy
case seed, and they have a sensitivity to that because they have an immune sensitivity to it.
We're not really looking at the genes. So really, when I look at a person's gene profile,
we pretty much ignore this first piece, except it does give me some
gravity to push them to what I already tell most people to go out of gluten free diet any home.
Because inflammation in the gut equals inflammation in the brain,
and inflammation in the brain equals problems in the rest of the body.
So if you're not already gluten free, and we're going to have lunch here in a little while,
it's probably going to be bread. I believe I fall into the category that I think everybody should
be gluten free because it's highly inflammatory to your gut. And when you have inflammation in the
gut, you have inflammation in the brain. So we'll move on. This also tests for peanut allergy genes.
Now, I don't see people particularly for allergies anymore. I see mainly cancer in line patients,
and even this person doesn't have a known peanut allergy, but she has two defects,
single allele defects in both the peanut allergy genes. Now also, if you're fairly compromised,
health-wise, you probably shouldn't be eating peanuts any home because they have a lot of
mycotoxins involved, nobody should really be eating a lot of peanuts, right? But certainly,
if you have the defects, you should not be eating peanuts, okay? Still with me? All right,
so there are some genes for caffeine consumption, and how well you detoxify caffeine. That's the
last one, that caffeine metabolism. This person has a double allele defect. In this particular case,
this variant actually helps you detoxify, metabolize caffeine much quicker. Before we had the gene profile,
I'd say, is caffeine good for your bad for you? Well, does caffeine make you have to go to the
bathroom? Yeah, I drink about three cups of coffee, and I run a night to go urinate. Well,
then you have the gene that metabolizes caffeine very quickly, and caffeine isn't necessarily bad for
you. No, I could drink a whole pot of coffee and it doesn't make me go to the bathroom. Well,
then you shouldn't be drinking coffee. But now we can look at the genetic picture and say, should you be
drinking coffee or shouldn't be drinking coffee? And this person would be fine drinking a little coffee.
But if you had a blade there, then you probably shouldn't be drinking very much coffee.
Follow me? But that's just kind of a fun one. That's what we're dealing with real health or not.
Now, we start to get into real sickness. Your FUT2 genes actually know in the new gene profiles. Now,
understand the software that we use. We're constantly adding new genes as discoveries are made,
because this is literally a new science. So, new research is coming out literally daily
on what the different genes do. So, we did this human genome project. You know, in America, they
gathered all this information of all the different genes, and they realized that there's a whole
lot less than they thought there was, and now they're trying to figure out what these different genes
do. The FUT2 genes responsibility is very important when it comes to your gut, because your gut health
has to do with a number of different things. The cells of the intestinal tract have to be tightly
packed together. That's how they are when you're bored, and they only allow things through that you
have receptors for, or that are swollen up that can sneak through between the cells. So, if we have
a healthy cell membrane, a healthy cell wall, a healthy cells of the intestinal tract, then we're
going to have a healthier disposition overall. However, there's all sorts of things that damage are
gut. So, there's genetically modified foods that damage are gut, there's inflammatory things that
damage are gut, medications, chemicals, yada, yada, yada, there's a zillion things that damage are
gut. What do we have a damage gut? I said, that could equal a damaged body, because remember I've
said in past, you are what you absorb, right? So, you aren't just what you eat, you are what you
absorb. Let's use an example. Well, I'm not supposed to eat a lot of fish from like Michigan, because it
has mercury in it. So, I better not, you know, I'm limited to the amount of fish. Actually, do you have
absorption sites in your gut for mercury? No, but do you probably have a damage gut that mercury is
going to be able to leak through and get into your bloodstream? Yes. So, if you had a perfectly
healthy gut, eat some mercury and your fish shouldn't bother you. You should expel it into the toilet.
However, when I have a damage gut membrane, in my epithelial cells and my gut are spread apart,
all things get through, that works, a lot of things get through, that we're supposed to get through,
that I make myself toxic, and I make myself inflamed, because my immune system responds to these
things that never should have been in my bloodstream in the first place, and my immune system goes,
what in the heck is that? Let's kill it. And it fires an inflammatory response. When there are food
particles, peptides of gluten and other things, and having metals and toxins and things like that,
those things don't die when your immune system tries to kill it, and all you do has is have this
systemic inflammatory process going on. Follow me? Health of the gut equals health of the body.
When you have inflammation of the gut, you also have inflammation in the brain. So, it's really
important to have a healthy gut. Your FUT2 genes, now there's only three listed here,
now in our new reports, I think there's 20. These are responsible for making an enzyme that makes the
healthy vucosolayer that lines the attestinal tract. So, the vucosolayer that lines the attestinal
tract, you can think of as the apartment building for your microbiota to live. So, your microbiota or
your normal flora, the good bacteria that lives symbiotically in your gut that help kill off pathogens,
that help keep a balance. You guys still with me? Okay? So, if I have FUT2 gene defects like this
poor person right here, double allele defects in all three of them, they do not have the carpenters
to make the healthy apartment building for the microbiota to live, for birth. So, even let's pretend
give this person the best case scenario. They had a mother who did not take drugs, did not ever take
antibiotics, inherited through the mother's breast bill a wonderful microbiota, that normal healthy
flora layer. So, they have a perfect microbiota. The mom did not give her antibiotics at all during her
early years, which would destroy the microbiota. Let's pretend they have a perfect microbiota. But
they have these FUT2 gene defects so they don't make a really healthy mucosa layer. And now they get
live at 23 years old and they go on a doctor's cycling for early life, which really and live won't
be the right thing to do. But it also wipes out the healthy microbiota that they had. And now having
the FUT2 gene defects, it's very hard to get that back. So, the people that we see with FUT2
gene defects have a very difficult time chronic with chronic health conditions because they have a very
difficult time keeping a healthy microbiota. Yes. So, what do we suggest? You're getting the animals.
So, this is very important. These FUT2 genes are really super important. And with the patient
base that I see, we see people that have a lot of defects here. Not all of them have double
little defects at all of them. This person is really having a difficult time. So, then you go back to
last year's right symposium to learn how to heal the gut.